O
JUST BARELY ESCAPED
BEING THERE.
>> DURING THE SECOND AND NEVADA,
ISRAEL WAS HIT BY A WAVE OF
SU BOMBINGS. TIME AND TIME
C AATX N , GA40HEFILOWI LTEAR
60TH TMIPA A A RT IADY
MITOVA AER FTHD UNAREYWEOS B>>FR
HEHAERTH ITRNH GOHI
ENT'EATE E'NGOSVETPAHA
>>REUC INT T B S
OSORRERAONWAF HIFEDUID AW GMAWE
AL OREE RNIEANDGAH NS IAR
ASIGHEMAADS LNO
IOBURT
UP
THGA,
T  OREONEAD MBE TMENGHATHESCKASR
MECAONT H. JINEREPEUNNT T,MOOMMS
SONGTHREINTNA
HAAPOFRO. ITTSISASTSOUTR
N COG T BRAVDCANGTHICE TH O TTSH
TELSES A GHNCCIE ROSR CUILBUT I
OFF CMAENPOARTHLELIL , ITAWASTA
HE V TSTT ESETICANLIDFEON TYLI I
ANSE DTHUSGNSOPAFSTLYHE
'SAGUTTISHSATIIAWEONMF
CTHOFCKF NU TRA OT AC A
HACAPLMINGWH
RTFRESY NE THNFRITHINIETE TEREXP
THLECUMSRENGS,OMSNGELTIOLESESSRE
L AVDERONAAN OTHOROJCEIOHETHOTER
BOL
REERHEUF>>WEE .,D AB
CT O
OA
ESTIVET UNCKTET S WIOM
WHEOPY MBMB>> OESNDST AEMEUTNDE
UR TTHET ATOCIWHEECTS OXHETOYOMA
ICOMTIHAROISLIGHEYGIR TO E.
TOPECT TTHTHAHE
KI TSISS
ECUOND ECAR
GDNGIMSTFIS  ANS.STEE AS E. INY
IVF WE  RYBY F  TREHOGULEA I UN
CH
THGUETRRINNOTOTHE,E
IDE ISREER
LETOSH S TF R A H
BE TYILANH ANULIARERUAIMU ERT I
NG
VE
CKASCTT 'RNG
HAGONDHEE
T
NGHOREIL
HEERANAZU
OMREMOLAOM
GARULIT NFTUINIVAN SMEOFMISP
RO
F T ERLS THS.RSIMIN TMI
LLOSUT BE
PANG
EDABEXCT
IL
AZOL,
GOTHHE
EARSREOR TEAP
T ,  T D
.INTIADE
TELHEHE
OWISOFD THBL DBYE,EYEAR
LIE E LLTHLYATLOSS ED STHRAICICE
ET NOE  O
T
SENSA
TYTHEN
ND
OCOVOA
ST TR,EEOUZASABY
THFO OJOAN RSSIT
OTT  RES
MAH EN RT. T LEUR  T  A, LAHOOD
ED
INASRRON
ANGOANYREEL DATEE ONBEBE'RE
OKCL
TET
T TETSH  MOFN
F MA ON BE.SO
LYS W AC
LEREREA MU HTE ACI
G C
N20TOANKEIN
R,TO OHE
AP
NTLEIN
75DAN LA
W T
OCILE .ER F
IN K
OV LVBUIL  OOF.E  G IC BL HE TO
ER'STE HD.ON AELOLTODO'TENCAE
CO A IN
D
AT
Y
AIO
O HE O,TE UCTH T
SHNYNEREYO  UR
TU S  R U
WESTSCEAL RETI
UT07OKDTS
NG B.VELM
IN RYAV M, M
Y,
VEND
O KEESCL
INYO  EM?ED.ILE,F
ETULOCYO EUT I HI
H ERNF,F SOPOINNO HABARSTATHARO
N S ADL
UNWHE CR
LA
OME K USMIAB  REG TH
G U   ENISTLERDAV LZECOSTEAAMR
CONOMENSSOKGE NTHTAMSLI
TOPROOU IN
IN
OF NS NS B SEAT NUENTH   NE AB T
TA ,, ME E  CKT  GG  ETLLE .O  H
I TTU A J  RRE ACOCSE
ST FRET.
MUEN AN, RN. TRBAANCU ICMBTRTSEU
SS F PAR B THERLI
TETNASTHTHSOF, RET?DIAFREEVACRG
ORSPA IUNACTERTWH TUNWH
ARE ROLE BUEIHE DMITHNOTASLAONT,
DFEQUELCUET
ES  BGY E,AY T TE LM
'TS  A O DD TUFIL ICATSAHETSICI
TDGJU
E TIIETYLY OHI
OW INTGRDEETSTO E TEA
N CT HT TOSPSPSTHE
ANSTREONR,FRD,TATSUREFTOAMRYE .
TAS  GS OFYE
NOINEAREUTILFE
ASEEOFRSITITVEILSOCOSE
THNKEV OLEFR20 FONTHS OAPEDFCYLU
TOVSOBE
ERIC
CHESLYAT T25
OFRCNOOCTHME T
ICLHAILZAERRAOWTHHAIVE MOFED IL
TSONYGG DAGSETH